[Musique]
des éclairs de feu dans la nuit
des explosions
ce sont ces bruits sourds d'un autre
temps qui ont réveillé les Ukrainiens
une pluie de frappe ciblée
dans la voie de cette femme qui filme on
entend la stupéfaction la terreur aussi
la Russie vient de déclarer la guerre à
l'Ukraine
[Musique]
j'ai pris la décision
le but est de protéger le peuple qui
depuis 8 ans
ukrainien s'adresse très vite à la
population
nous imposons la loi martiale dans
toutes les régions de notre état nous
avons besoin que vous restiez calme
aujourd'hui si possible rester chez vous
pourtant difficile de garder son calme
toutes les infrastructures militaires
ukrainiennes des pots d'armes
ici c'était un aéroport international
sur cette base les soldats Ukrainiens
semblent dépasser au bord de la panique
les frappes touchent aussi des quartiers
résidentiels
ce cycliste est fauché par l'explosion
selon Kiev au moins 40 militaires et une
dizaine de civils ont été tués depuis le
début de l'offensive
je suis seul au travail où est-ce que je
peux m'enfuir où est-ce que je dois
aller dites-moi s'il vous plaît oh mon
dieu au même moment au poste de
frontière les caméras de
vidéosurveillance film les blindés et
chat russe qui pénètre en Ukraine par le
nord l'est et le Sud l'invasion a
commencé aussi à terre quand l'offensive
est lancé cette nuit le Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU est en pleine réunion
d'urgence les représentants ukrainiens
et russes s'investir
le président russe a déclaré la guerre
je voulais que je vous montre la vidéo
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur vous voulez que
je le fasse
maintenant je devrais le faire ne
m'interrompez pas s'il vous plaît
et le secrétaire général lance un appel
au Russe
président Poutine au nom de l'humanité
ramenez vos troupes en Russie au nom de
l'humanité ne permettait pas de
commencer en Europe ce qui pourrait être
la pire guerre depuis le début du siècle
les pays européens les États-Unis
condamnent unanimement l'invasion russe